this is a Fox News Alert a democratic  staff at our on Capitol Hill has been  arrested for allegedly publishing the  private information of US senators  during the Brett Kavanaugh hearing last  week private phone numbers and home  addresses of Republican centers were  posted online it was apparently an  effort to promote harassment  intimidation who knows what else against  those lawmakers now authorities believe  they have arrested the man who did it he  is called Jackson Cusco he's an intern  for congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee of  Texas Costco also previously worked for  Democratic senators Barbara Boxer and  Maggie Hassan of New Hampshire he's been  charged with burglary witness tampering  making threats and identity theft in  relation to these actions will of course  continue to follow the story